[Music]
in the anals of human history few
individuals have left an impact as
profound and enduring as the ancient
Greek philosopher Socrates a thinker
ahead of his time Socrates remains a
Bedrock of Western philosophical
tradition he's frequently praised not
just for his contributions to philosophy
but also for his unique method of
inquiry and his indomitable commitment
to the truth in this video I will
attempt a close examination of his life
methodologies and teach ings so we can
discern why Socrates remains a highly
admired figure Millennia after his
passing Socrates is born in Athens
Greece to sopon nus a stone Mason and
fin arity a midwife growing up during
the Golden Age of Athens Socrates was
exposed to a city that was a hub for art
thought and politics although
information about his Early Education is
spse it's likely he was taught music
gymnastics grammar and philosophy as
were most Athenian
[Music]
youths in the ponan war Socrates served
as a hoplight a heavily armed food
soldier in several campaigns during this
war between Athens and Sparta his
bravery during these battles especially
at POA and dilum became widely
recognized after the war Socrates begins
to gain prominence in Athens for his
unique method of questioning everything
and everyone which eventually became
known as the Socratic method he did not
belong to a school nor did he ever write
down his teachings instead he preferred
engaging in dialogues with Athenians
challenging them to question their
beliefs and think
critically Socrates unconventional
methods and beliefs eventually led to
his trial on charges of impiety and
corrupting the Youth of Athens found
guilty by a jury he sentenced to death
Socrates is executed by being forced to
drink a concoction containing poison
hemlock instead of escaping Athens when
given the opportunity he chose to accept
his sentence a decision that further
solidified his legacy as a paragon of
virtue and
[Music]
integrity throughout philosophical
history few relationships have been as
potent and consequential as that between
Plato and his mentor Socrates Plato is
best known for his philosophical
dialogues wherein he often employs
Socrates as his primary protagonist
through these dialogues Plato both
immortalized Socrates and provided
future generations with a lens through
which to view and understand Socratic
philosophy at the heart of many platonic
dialogues is the figure of Socrates
characterized by an insatiable appetite
for inquiry the socratic method is a
dialectical form of questioning to
stimulate critical thinking for example
in meno Menon in Greek Socrates States
I'm not teaching the boy anything but
only asking him questions this quote
underscores Socrates belief in the power
of questions and the innate human
ability to discover truths Plato often
paints Socrates as a paragon of virtue
in the apology where Socrates defends
himself against charges of impiety and
corrupting the youth he says the only
true wisdom is knowing that you know
nothing this profound humility and
acknowledgment of human limitation are
Central to Socratic wisdom as presented
by Plato Plato's theory of forms is one
of his most significant contributions to
philosophy and he uses Socrates to
articulate this in dialogues like fedo
and the Republic Socrates discussing the
world of immutable and eternal forms
posits in fedo we recognize absolute
Beauty and absolute goodness by
comparing them with relative Beauties
and relative Goods through Socrates
Plato propounds that our Earthly
experiences are but Shadows of these
perfect forms a recurring theme in
Plato's portrayal of Socrates is the
notion of Socratic ignorance in the
apology Socrates mentions the delish
Oracle Proclamation that no man is wiser
than Socrates but as he States what can
the god mean for I know that I have no
wisdom great or small through this Plato
emphasizes that true wisdom lies in
recognizing one's own ignorance and it
is this self-awareness that drives the
pursuit of
knowledge rooted in dialogue and
Relentless questioning the Socratic
method seeks to uncover underlying
beliefs challenge assumptions and
stimulate critical thinking the methods
s Ence is captured in his famous quote
the unexamined life is not worth living
through the application of this approach
Socrates aim to unravel complex ideas
and cultivate an authentic understanding
of the world the Socratic method is
characterized by several distinct
tenants Cooperative argumentative
dialogue instead of providing direct
answers the method revolves around a
series of questions meant to guide the
respondent towards a realization or an
insight as Socrates stated in Plato's
meno I'm not teaching him I'm merely
questioning him elenos or elenos in
Greek which means testing this is the
practice of refuting a position by
demonstrating contradictions within that
position the intent isn't to defeat an
opponent but to collaboratively arrive
at a closer approximation of the truth
acknowledgement of ignorance fundamental
to the socratic approach is the
admission of of One's Own ignorance this
humility forms the foundation for
genuine inquiry as Socrates professed in
Plato's apology I know that I am
intelligent because I know that I know
nothing to illustrate the Socratic
method let's consider some examples from
Plato's dialogues in eifo aifon in Greek
Socrates encounters eifo who claims to
have a clear understanding of piety that
is the quality of being religious
Socrates adopting his characteristic
approach asks uif to Define piety as uif
offers various definitions Socrates
through systematic questioning reveals
the inconsistencies and contradictions
in each definition this process not only
underscores the complexity of the
concept but also highlights the dangers
of superficial understanding another
example is from meno where Socrates
engages a slave boy in a geometric
inquiry about the properties of squares
without directly teaching the boy
Socrates through a series of questions
guides him to derive a mathematical
truth on his own this illustrates the
idea that knowledge isn't always about
external acquisition but can be an act
of recollection and internal
realization to contextualize the trial
one must first understand the
intricacies of Athenian democracy while
a is often celebrated as the Cradle of
democratic governance it was a direct
democracy deeply influenced by public
opinion and sentiments every male
citizen had a say in matters of state
and legal proceedings were no exception
the court system allowed for accusers to
bring forward complaints and the jury
consisting of a large body of citizens
would decide the fate of the accused
Socrates faced two primary charges
impiety against the pantheon of Athens
and corrupting the youth with his
revolutionary ideas on the surface these
accusations might seem a product of
personal enmity or political
machinations but delving deeper one
discerns a society grappling with rapid
changes in thought and values Socrates
with his Relentless questioning of
established beliefs and societal Norms
posed the significant challenge to
Athenian Traditions his open critique of
the Gods and his encouragement for their
youth to question and think critically
were seen as direct threats to the
stability and continuity of Athenian
Society Plato's the apology provides a
detailed account of Socrates defense
during the trial instead of adopting an
appeasing tone Socrates in
characteristic fashion used the trial as
an opportunity to expound on his
philosophy he asserted that his method
of questioning was not a corrupting
influence but a Divine Mission a calling
from the Oracle ad Deli to stimulate
self-awareness and intellectual rigor
among the Athenians Socrates contended
that his role was analogous to a gadfly
stinging the massive horse of Athenian
State into wakefulness and action the
jury consisting of 501 Athenians found
Socrates guilty the prosecution proposed
the death penalty they probably expected
a counter proposal for Exile but instead
Socrates OD iously proposed to the jury
that he be rewarded not punished
according to Plato Socrates asked the
jury for free meals in the panum a
public dining hall in the center of
Athens he was subsequently sentenced to
die by consuming poison hemlock the
decision wasn't just the verdict of a
court but reflected the broader associal
discomfort with radical thought that
challenges the status quo the trial and
execution of Socrates had profound
implic ations in the short term it
exposed the vulnerabilities of Athenian
democracy where majority rule could
sometimes suppress minority voices
especially those that diverged sharply
from mainstream thought in the long run
however it elevated Socrates from a
critical thinker of his age to a
Timeless symbol of intellectual courage
and martyrdom for the cause of free
thought the trial also serves as a
cautionary tale for all democratic
societ ities it underscores the
importance of safeguarding free speech
and thought it reminds us that the true
strength of a democracy lies not just in
the voice of the majority but in its
ability to protect and cherish diverse
voices that dare to challenge and
question the trial of Socrates stands as
a seminal event in Western intellectual
history it encapsulates the Perpetual
tension between Innovation and tradition
between individual conscience and
societal expectations Socrates
unwavering commitment to his beliefs
even in the face of death remains a
testament to the enduring power of
philosophy and the human
[Music]
spirit